oh yeah what happened they get a sweet
and stuff i don't know
they drove to vegas from louisiana
together
all right and that's that you know was
your friend a gay man you think
again the aerosmith concert was in vegas
that's a good point
it's all full circle the truth is nick
is that man's son
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
i never heard of a diet like that like
hey but if you stumble on a burger
that's my life go ahead and get it
that's my life a lot of murderers out
there man yeah you want to have
no i've worn enough shitty hats on this
show
we already got two blind mice in here
too thick behind me
you know i found out you know i told you
i've been doing that diet yeah
every week yeah forever no i had always
no i got meals now right i'm serious
about this so i get these meals
last night three a.m i'm start i woke up
starve and roll around like damn i'm not
going to sleep i need some food what am
i going to do
i'm like this can't be right man the
portions don't look normal
so i call them this morning i literally
haven't slept since 3am so hungry
lightheaded right now depressed
so eye-headedness is also one of your
natural characteristics
so i called don't start blinking that's
fair
that's not keto but i like to chalk it
up but i called the food company i said
yo man i'm
starving and they said well let's look
at the computer here see what you got
oh we made a mistake what do you mean
they go you're on a thousand calorie
diet a day
no i said ma'am i am 260 goddamn pounds
we are so sorry
bring your next few meals free what
that's the leash
[Laughter]
it seems like they owed it to you they
owed it to you dude i saw you yesterday
yeah eating some little
mcnugget or something that thing i was
like yeah
oh that was my lunch time tickets
and that was my dinner too bro dude i
said if that if they killed that chicken
with that little
with that little stick i said i felt
that was the smallest littlest chicken
ever bro
that's like chin fishing oh kill them
small dog they kill them small i'm down
three pounds daddy
nine thousand pound calorie diet yeah
why don't you just stay on the diet and
tough it out
i'm going to dude if you can stay
jacking off i'll stay on the diet so
this is your lifestyle night
yeah welcome my lifestyle dang dude
not a thousand how many weeks how many
weeks we'll see man i'm light-headed
right now a little irritable
you look like john mayer of snacks
slow dancing in a burning room baby i
feel like yeah
i feel like john mayer always hurts that
he does uh yeah mr bell looked like
brooks and dumb
we've never seen no i've never seen a
picture of chappelle in school dude he's
always
dancing in the gym yeah it's always
recess where chabelle is
oh he's doing flips yeah a lot of the
kids in the background are in wheelchair
or something like
this seemed like a unique environment i
did take the short bus when i was
younger
yeah oh what happened nothing happened
to me you get roasted when you got off
because at my school the
short bus kids got
i don't condone that but that's just the
way the world oh one of the sv
kids came one time in our school when
dude he'd had enough right he had enough
of his shoot that [ __ ] up
uh he brought a bunch of uh blazing
rockets hand rockets whatever those
things are called
black cat sparkles
rockets yeah and he just started
unleashing on people in this background
you can still
you know you know attack people at
school with fire but not like
guns you know and not be sent home for
the rest of the year yeah yeah
and he got you know they made him stay
outside and pick up garbage or something
for half the day
that's how it should be dude that's what
that's what i had to do in junior high
they gave me community service every
[ __ ] dude that wasn't junior high if
you got community service court
also also you're probably a grown man in
junior high
kids don't get community service dogs
that's what they did to me
i promise you yes this is arizona
somebody like
you know a lot about where you were when
you were a kid man did they
yeah somebody's like oh you just have to
take this short bus just because
that's insane even though you're a real
thing
even though you're 18 you're in junior
high
i don't know how they do in arizona bro
yeah
you gotta i think we gotta delve into
your history a little bit tighten up
yeah
yeah we wanted to get you into one of
those on like uh
you might have to do gh uh b or
something what is it called
where you get your degrees that's a drug
that's it yeah
i'm down to watch him do ghb but i'm
also down for him to get his ged
yes i graduated high school
i know i did didn't i yeah yeah i did
yeah i did
all right i think i got a picture we're
not saying you did it man we're just
saying a lot of the references i'm just
saying maybe go back over and
kill you yeah yeah i want to be in a cap
and gown
i promise that doesn't prove anything
yeah i could buy one right now hold on
man
no yo dude i think you were in the
church choir i don't know
what that was a fusion oh no yeah i've
been to a lot of afam churches and it is
everybody's in it everybody's in a cap
and gown in that thing
where i graduate even at the funerals
every now and then you'll see just like
some
the black out of the coffin will be like
he'll just pop up
i mean everybody that's one picture i
got some school pictures y'all hating
i think you're confusing community
service with graduation
i know i did it didn't i do it dog nick
nicki minaj was like yeah we had the
license plate making class
no i'm telling you the class i'll tell
you where is that
oh no there you are right yeah look at
that bad boy again
look at that bad boy oh he's
bullshitting around
bad boy is correct dude that's obviously
a kid
who would have been uh taken out of
class for some reason no that was that
was a legend oh yeah you went double
button
yeah come on man look at my full latin i
got my team
right here look go ahead nick show that
one that's in high school the latino top
button
let's see some of these other freaking
alleged were all your friends uh
latino in uh oh this ain't school
chappelle
yeah that's what that's my cheer photo
again not school that's an
outside activity oh you and a bunch of
marilyn manson looking to win
yeah he was i thought they took this off
netflix
[Laughter]
yeah man oh there it is there it is this
is cute
there you go i was a g let's see one
more
one more let's see one more of you not
graduating
hey i'm right there you see me this
ain't college bro no
i see no degree that was miss classics
class bro come on now
you're telling me dude little dude on
the bottom left that that dude's in
college bro
well that's not called a little illegal
you know that dude's over there bro
damn who's that big button next to you
with a hat on
where big old mean gene with the hat on
in the blue dress
valedictorian yeah yeah who's that
little skirt on your on your right
who's lizzo on the far right top rope
[Laughter]
dude they put me in the middle were you
were you going to school florida dude
this definitely seems that's in arizona
wow oh yeah yeah yeah i like it i like
the mix though
i see what do you like to mix well i'm
just saying it's there's the minority is
the white
the white there yeah that's yeah too
white is there any other black people in
there
no it's just you a lot of latino ones
scared white girl in the middle
you got that hawaiian girl in the bottom
right dude that white that white dude
uh right no no no no
go down the guy he's got like the no go
up go up the blonde white kid
that one yes that [ __ ] was a nut
oh yeah he looks like
crazy dude i could have guessed i could
he probably killed his parents i don't
know probably by then that's one of
those kids that'll hide a grape in his
butt dude
for no reason i went to school with a
kid who killed his parents
all right
[Laughter]
but what grade did he do he did it i
think he was like uh
he graduated and then him and his
brother were on
the run for a day or something you're
talking about the menendez brothers
no they're the indians they're cool
they're older than india
so they were indian and they killed the
parents yeah it was just one of those
things where like
the younger brother seemed like a good
kid but then the older brother you
always kind of knew he was a little off
like there's always one we still don't
know to this day they're in prison
obviously
uh i think the oldest one is youngest i
think
got out wow yeah the younger one usually
gets out because a lot of times the
the younger one will be able to plead
that like the older one forced them to
talk to them into it let them do it yeah
they're indian so it's like a
asian honor culture thing wow the oldest
always has to take responsibility
oh yeah and a lot of indian people drink
also and do
reservation indians like yeah the
indians are talking about no like
individuals
reservation or wait to be seeded indians
wait to be seated
okay dot indians or feather indians
okay all right damn
that's yeah that's not chocolate i got
you guys a gift
i got you guys a gift from nashville and
i forgot it last week i just saw that in
the uh gift shop of our
hotels for the pisces brothers i didn't
get anybody else anything because no one
else pays me
all right but you know because
this could go nowhere or they could be
fun maybe tell you what is it
is it not chocolate does it at least
come with a stick of gum
it says uh astrology card set follow the
stars
pisces february 19th to march 20th
pisces bro come with a jewelry too
oh [ __ ] dog i'm gonna put that on you i
shout now
oh i'm getting that jewelry on bro do we
have the same one minus two fish
mine is two fish two yeah that's what a
pisces is yeah
yeah that's that's real that's real
silver now is it mm-hmm
okay next week i'll have some chocolate
in front of in front of you
since i know don't tempt me dogs i can't
miss the diet here's some strengths
here's some of your strengths i'll read
these
because this is astrology sign that's
what i was looking for
and this is some of your strengths
brendan it'd be your strengths too right
yeah yeah all right so some of my
strengths are compassionate
artistic intuitive
gentle yeah yeah pretty gentle wise
correct musical i like music
so but liking music doesn't make you
musical brandon that's insane
well i do want to play the guitar this
is why i don't believe in astrology you
guys don't have the same strengths
i don't think no you're different now
here's some of your weaknesses burning
in these holes
and the only reason i even read the
strings was so i could read these
but i'm gonna go ahead and jump in this
one weird because i found the same card
some of your weaknesses okay scared yep
indecisive whoa dreamy
yeah also known as out to lunch
[Laughter]
first of all the term is good second of
all extremely
shocked you would ever use that term
oversensitive yeah both of us check
[ __ ] kill people uh quick
okay we talking running or mentally what
are we talking about a weakness
that single leg is a weakness yeah what
that's what
yeah i don't know you did hit me with
that single leg you have to sprawl on
your [ __ ] ass
you need to do that same thing to big
old mean gene man hit that [ __ ] with a
single leg oh i'll get in on her get her
[ __ ] titty
mats on the floor you know it says
tempered
brennan's angry huh i know yeah it's
this diet dog
i know yeah yeah have something man nope
and this is your stay wild moon child
that's you
yeah oh lucky days uh lucky days uh
thursday and sunday so yeah okay
thursday's all right i like fridays
myself
whatever i like thursdays lucky numbers
three and seven you like three and seven
i like 22 is my lucky number and 11.
oh this is this is weird this hits it on
the head uh most likely be molested
oh does it say that yeah that's super
specific bring up this
actually let's get into an article from
my home area uh
langenstein if you google langenstein
over there nola
langenstein yeah nola i just don't get
what the rest of these cards are for
uh are you supposed to play like tarot
cards you trade them they had some
pedophile stuff happen
little pet pedophile you notice how many
pedophile rings are getting shut down
since they caught that lady maybe he's
gonna know
eight one lady or click on the news yeah
the the homegirl who was uh epstein's
uh former de la salle principal right
there the principal shown his wiener for
cinnamon
you're getting stories mixed up yeah
you're getting things mixed up am i
but this guy is this the same guy did it
do you know
the same guy that tried to molest me in
my buddies right here i [ __ ] thought
he got mentioned in a paper yesterday
former dallas saul principal another
religious brother
accused of molesting a student in the
80s whoa when were you there in the 90s
but that was in the two i was in all
yeah in the late 90s almost 2000s but
in uh langenstein he died oh he's dead
and that and then they came out with it
or is the one still alive
he died keep going down where it gets to
saint tammany parish over there
and it says he did a little bit of
molesting over there the plaintiff who
attended oh he attended from 81.85 now
we're getting closer
yeah he ran a school over there uh
august 7th lawsuit appears the first
time
the service of the 71 year old pleaded
no contest to charges of child
molestation for unrelated conduct in st
tammany parish boy now what son damn no
content no content but still that's easy
it's almost like saying hey it could
have happened
you know and if it could have happened
and it's molestation that's
risky enough yeah
dude how about how about your boy from
cheer jerry
doing well you're a boy first of all
that's what i said and then he takes
offense to it yeah you're
you know better than we do oh jerry
harris have you ever met him
i have not and no i have not and
uh i don't know i got nothing to say
i don't know him though but still cheer
is also kind of a gateway drug
for being molested i feel like you guys
get a lot molested
yeah it's always weird it's always weird
when you got those older
dudes in their 20s playing with kids
well langenstein we used to buy us weed
and he would buy
steaks and we'd go over there see again
this sounds like a good time
that's what we all thought man we're
over there smoking weed out of an apple
this guy's 71 years old eating t-bones
oh man i've never even seen a steak dude
that's living brother
again sounds like a nice guy put on
music for you yeah what did it do
yeah we would listen to music we'll
watch the saints games have big cookies
yeah and the next you know but yeah and
then one time he got us some baked
potatoes and uh
and this is how it all went down so we
got us some baked potatoes and
how often would you go over there i went
like every week
because i was like oh this dude good guy
yeah this dude
i'm still trying to find a hole in this
man's life well here's where i got
risque
okay so i was in the kitchen one time
and uh
and i said i was having baked potatoes i
said hey uh
my buddy scott said hey do you have any
sour cream he yelled that
and i said no but you have some of this
sweet cream i was joking talking about
semen
talking about that thick sweet sweat
that's how bobby lee says
so uh i said no you can have some of
this sweet cream right just joking
hilarious and then big richard the guy
who died
uh he goes can i have some
and no one thought it was funny and
that's when everybody
was like oh he's not just here to grill
we went from high kids eating steaks
with an old man
to like oh my god man this guy's gonna
freaking suck the tartar sauce out of it
he got a risque chin you ever been
molested you're good
any old man ever put his meat on your
grill oh sure
no i think it's hard to get my life
you're not a if you're a if you are
a handsome asian kid i don't see how you
don't get one that's amazing
you see how big he was oh that's
immediate like oh who's this
older guy and like i'm 11. like sure you
are buddy
they draw a mustache on you and date you
for a month
were you were you big when you were a
kitchen no i was tiny i
i had like a growth spur from junior
high to high school like a foot and a
half or two
yeah so you're real cute that little
tiny with big cheeks
a little korean chick stuff this little
freaking cornucopia huh
but yeah remember there's nuts in your
mouth no now do you get to do
do do younger semi-asian man get
do you get hit on by asian men or all
types of older men do you feel like
well because i see it more of as a
delicacy that's a good question still
you know what i'm saying i see that you
get hit by a lot of men no i remember i
did go clubbing before
and then i got hit on by like a white
dude yeah yeah
and he was like yeah you did yeah you
did boy yeah that's what you get for
coming around these parts
[Music]
yeah this this was in like uh like
newport beach it's like
chester drawers it's a it's a barcode
yeah
you have a few so basically back then i
wore like abercrombie and fitch and
hollister kind of stuff and i was
working out so i was like
kind of jacked cute
check checks so he just came up to
because hey uh you ever considered being
a model i'm telling you this actually
happened
you could be modeling you tell them i go
no not really goes well i think you
should
you should here's my card just give me a
call sometime uh we should probably like
you know get you started on modeling
yeah
so i think that's the closest thing i've
ever been hit on so it's far
no you didn't go you didn't want to be a
model you could have been in front
of a real career i did not believe it
you could have been a model dude
dude again sounds like a nice guy giving
you opportunity and you think
he's over here trying to suck you off
you could have been model lasted
you freaking passed it up yeah look
where you actually had big dreams or
something you're out of your mind
yeah you're lost you could be living in
florida right now god with everybody
else
playing the guitar that's all you'd ask
in the morning you play the guitar
with the lights on but it's a good thing
i didn't go because look where i'm at
now
i guess i guess man how do you feel
he got some t-bones out of his deal yeah
it is a great opportunity
dude i'll tell you this man if i have
any more liquid inside of my body
gosh bro i dude i could it's crazy how
much liquid i shook somebody's hand
earlier and their hand was all wet
yeah your nickname aquaman doug oh dude
i cried for like an hour and a half and
i wasn't even sad dude
i cried and i licked the tears oh yeah
they're good man now that is what i'm
saying is liquid iv
oh i love it in the old days you get
hydration in your body you don't know
what it is what is it
dude salt water what is it how about
liquid iv said hey
you fellas like caffeine also how about
you can get 100 milligrams of caffeine
doug with your liquid iv they got that
extra hitter they
get hydrated and get uh fly draided baby
though that [ __ ] will g you up
dude i like to take you straight to the
vein dude i'll babysit a freaking hot
air balloon dog you know what i'm saying
i'm gonna be
lifted after that gift i love it it's so
tasty my energy's good for the whole day
oh i'll eat my freaking cousin's tongue
dawg how do you use liquid iv
i'll just tell you you get home instead
of putting a needle in your arm and
dousing up
you mix it it's a powder but here's what
i notice about it
when i drink it i feel replenished you
feel better maybe not god you got that
hot energy
too that green energy blend one to two
cups of coffee energy without the crash
science they know that
hit them with the deal fat pack there's
a deal here's a deal sponge bob
liquid iv is available nationwide at
costco or
get 25 off when you go to liquid iv.com
use the code kats at checkout that's 25
of anything you order we need the
problem called cats at liquidity.com
bro yeah quick patrick
i ain't having it doug dude if there's a
line in the sand that's the line dog
and hey it's a wet line with liquid iv
but that's the line it's a windy day at
the beach
that line is disappearing fast 25
off anything you order when you use
promo code cats and liquid
[Laughter]
i think uh chin lied to us and he took
that man up on his offer because this is
a commercial that someone sent in for
cats in the wild
he got his gig give your business that's
it that's it
it's really all leading up to one oh
that cat's wild right there that's fast
but that looks like him it really does
jen uh it's a little bit there a little
bit the nose
he has those gauges those like i used to
have those two though yeah you did
you used to have gauges chin yeah but
not huge but it was like you know those
the silver ones yeah damn daddy
oh yeah are your ears still [ __ ] up
from it because i didn't keep it in
forever
so they're not [ __ ] up no no they're
not [ __ ] up
got it someone saw theo playing cricket
picking up a new sport
cricket's [ __ ] big time out there
what's that
starbucks snickerdoodle ordering food
yeah
the cricket one sucked it really was all
the lead up to this starbucks one
uh this is easily the most we've ever
sent in
of uh cats in the wild brendan is doing
a little moonlighting what are you doing
going after his passions
it looks like he took the business card
and really ran with the opportunities
dude that's gonna be me on this thousand
calorie diet
we're gonna mix that up and we're gonna
add our ice cubes to top it up
here's the deal did brian monarch make
this
dude his hair is dope man i'm on my way
you're just talking about getting that
hair
dude this guy's my spirit adam are you
from the future
yeah yeah brother
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i'll just say this that guy's ordered
more than a that guy's had more than a
double shot on his back
[Laughter]
and that's a little too much he's got
those long
shots
[Laughter]
can i have some
again your guy seems cool man i still
don't have an issue with this dog
all right he was he was adding on to
your joke man well here's what the crazy
thing i said marilyn manson a minute ago
richard langenstein took us to a marilyn
manson's concert when i was
probably 13 or 14 years old dude who's
cooking your steaks
at a concert too took us to marilyn
manson's concert bro and like good
tickets
a place as big as two of these offices
man real small it was a great time oh it
was insane the beautiful people the
beautiful
he's creepy though huh should i be
worried theo took me to an aerosmith
concert
just us
grabbed your hand when the armageddon
song came on
i don't want to code it was good nick
wasn't really into it
no i loved i loved it uh during that
song though stephen tyler tried to like
hold the mic out towards theo and theo
was away texting on his phone
[Music]
dude i was singing the whole time to the
one time you looked down i go down i
tried to get some girl's phone number
who was an escort obviously with some
older man
and i drugged her and she passed out
what happened wait what wait why didn't
you say that
this is the best night ever some guy
next to us had two women then i guess he
over drugged one of them or something
and she just passed
out bro
[Laughter]
it's sad too man yeah that guy's down a
party man man that sounds like a good
night though did you guys get some
steaks
dude and i just got like five digits of
her number before she passed all the way
out
the saddest part she's a cool girl
she was attractive she looks smart
she's smart yeah what does that mean
check out the big brain on brad
but damn man i still don't know if
chappelle finished school or not
that's all right yeah it's been
wondering about keeps going through his
phone
keep bringing up pictures of him at
recess on my instagram class comedian
i was class comedian still not a
graduating pit
in junior high chevelle come on bro you
keep
no yo don't hate me did you guys have
seen your quotes
yeah and i'll tell you who wouldn't know
okay
jabel's like here's a picture of me
graduating high school and it's him at
six years old yeah at a petting zoo and
you're like
dude that's you with a lizard yeah
he's last here's a picture of me
all right let me get one more here's a
picture of me getting my diploma and
he's in a
he's in a swim meet you're like again
doug that's a second place medal
chapelle
here's a ask your daddy when he comes
chappelle
here's a couple thottiana's right here
let's hit him up it's being a sweet
cream value
value dude hey brendan hey theo
king it or sing it lip fillers and botox
we love you guys tell us what you think
i'm not into it but i'll cheers
one two three four baddies a couple
shotties out there
huh i'm about to grill them some steak
fill me up
damn i'll take the page out your old
man's book can i have something
man langenstein dude he took one of my
friends to las vegas that's where he
oh yeah what happened to vase you get a
sweet and stuff i don't know they drove
to vegas from louisiana together
all right and that's that you know was
your friend a gay man you think um
again the aerosmith concert was in vegas
so that's a good point
it's all full circle the truth is nick
is that man's son
getting them back after all these years
[Laughter]
but it's just crazy because i was just
reading that article yesterday and that
guy uh which they said fillers or like
just any
cosmetics or botox uh i'm not mad at
it's when they overdo it or like when
girls overdo their lips
you know but i'm not i'm not mad at if
it makes your face look better as long
as you don't overdo it man
i got botox in my nose and it's uh
nothing ballooned up a little bit
so you can't have that but if they do it
right you know
like you can't you can't look at kylie
jenner tell me that that
these procedures didn't help her look
way better i mean
i don't think so i think you've seen her
before but here's it we'll never see
that girl in her chappelle's class pic
every picture that we even see of her
has been doctored or we'll never
see that's her right that's her right
there but that's also her as a
kid like her face
you tell me the nose the lips the cheek
implants the forehead implants
the wig the tits i'm not saying they
didn't help i'm just saying we don't
know what her full potential would have
been
well it wasn't that on the right
and they did not botch that i'll tell
you that right now
i don't i i i come on bro i don't know
come on bro when i was young if you got
you know
reparative surgery or something maybe
you got your arm fixed or something you
know
we had a guy whose arm was on kind of
upside down you know we had one of them
it went up from his body and set it down
you know and so they had to redo it when
we were in like fifth grade or something
because that's the thing oh it was crazy
because he always thought he was also in
class i was trying to ask a question and
the teacher would forget and all the
substitutes didn't know
they'd be like clark and you should be
like
hey remember the teacher wouldn't call
on you you'd have to do this you'd have
to use the post like this
oh
dude after 15 minutes like this and
brenda's question was always like oh
is it launched yet i was always can i go
to the bathroom can i go to the bathroom
trying to see my boys chill a little bit
talk [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
hallway dog dude you see a girl maybe
show my outfit act like i'm
[ __ ] sharp my pencil to show off my
fit you feel me
yeah i would do that that would be the
best man walking up to the pencil
sharpener
everybody see you yeah what's going on
new kicks you stupid [ __ ] yeah they're
like why are you sharpening
seven pennies i'd always go up there and
raise hell man
dude the best was when you got out of
class during class and you got to go
walk in the hall
and there was always like some [ __ ]
weirdos in there yeah it was always
strange
it was always like some kid who was like
getting called to the office for
something
and he's like i don't know man i don't i
didn't do it
you're like nice of course you didn't
shawn man i'm sure everything would be
cool and you knew he was [ __ ] that's
the last time you'd ever see him at
school he knew he was [ __ ]
he was [ __ ] he was an idiot and then
they would send those kids to that
remember is like the secondary school
the bad school
oh yeah got his degree that's where i
had to graduate from
yeah that's why i can't find it that's
why i can't find it
yeah i did it i did it though that was
freedom in the hallway though man
yeah oh it felt like a rebel i felt like
[ __ ] me
second you closed the door to that class
oh dude
and i come back 20 minutes later and
they're like
but the teachers were so glad that i was
gone because i've been raising such hell
in the classroom
you could tell they were low-key kind of
excited that i've been gone so long yeah
they know what's up did you find the
bathroom
oh i huh i forgot i even had to go to
the bathroom but the worst you have to
give the pass
back oh come on man was this [ __ ]
russia let me live
dude and you'd see like there'd always
be like uh
there'd always be out in the hall like
some teacher would be out there like
having to deal with some personal issue
the principal's not really walking down
the hall like what are you doing out
here theo
yep the worst is if uh you came back
took too long i wouldn't let all the
girls know in class i wasn't taking a
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh again it was crazy out there people
running around and stuff like
what dude i used to sneak into the
mentally challenged classroom next to
our class and steal all our candy bro
i feel bad about that and one time i
stayed in the cupboard in there and they
all came back in
and i had to do like a whole listen to a
whole lesson that they learned about
you would steal candy from me
[Laughter]
i didn't know stuck on that i didn't i
mean i guess i knew that someone were
mentally disabled but i didn't
they weren't fully they're like forrest
gump
some of them i mean they were definitely
at least a crescent moon of a brain you
know
okay so you're not talking anybody that
was running i'll tell you what you know
in college at dal ward that was the
athletic department there's this kid
right dal ward also sounds like a
[ __ ]
place where you go to school if you need
help yeah well it was where the
football team was at that's where the
weight room and stuff are and we'd go oh
yeah i remember
but there was this there's this dude
there i thought he was like 21 22 he had
a twin he's actually 44
and he had down syndrome and he'd always
wear matching sweats
top bottom same [ __ ] every day and have
him fold the towels and
fix the drinks and i thought he was
touching everybody's butt
because i'd go get a gatorade every time
before practice he always rubbed my butt
i thought yeah
i'll let him you know do his thing maybe
he thinks it's my back
and i was telling the team like how
about jerry was rubbing our asses am i
right
no i wasn't right i was getting molested
damn
they fired him so there's your story
they fired him he's just yours
it's so sad your stories bear in mind
because i didn't get steak out of it or
nothing
no aerosmith concert nothing i think if
somebody's gatorade
but if somebody has a disease or
something or a hand yeah
i felt i felt bad telling them no i
think you got to let them
touch you yeah just be nice you know
about it i was super don't make them
feel bad brendan i didn't i was super
nice
you got him fired no well he got fired
because he took all the hand towels
and put him into his sweats on his
genitals oh yeah so they had to fire him
over that
yeah damn so that's pretty sad
so you had a great high school
experience sure you did i was
back
next week you're gonna come in with a
photo of somebody else's diploma no
i got it i got i don't have the diploma
i don't have that oh yeah
i don't have an hour we're getting it
somewhere here we go
how would i get into college that's what
we want to know doing backflips
you're an athlete they'll they'll pull
some strings oh yeah oh totally man
okay um what else is going on cat how's
your relationship been
uh it's been all right okay so same old
same
problems chin you're going uh
camping going back to the same lake like
a chimney you can kill some of them
little fish
uh i'm actually you know i've we've
never been skunked before so i think
this time for sure i'm going to keep one
catch it and cook it what do you mean
yeah no no fish at all
we've always gotten fish there no matter
what can't you just say you
didn't catch fish they call it skunk
though fishing world
ketchup why is that thicky in the water
yeah
they're called pbs by the way uh why
what do you think
pretty bigs almost pretty bulky
kinda no one else let us keep guessing
hold on
nick hasn't gas neither is anybody else
let them guess if you get you call them
pbs if you got your biggest fish
of all time it's called your pb personal
best boom
all right nick and don't if you run a
small contest like that and you're
having people guess
don't do it that fast yeah
yeah so you're trying to get a personal
best out there first of all i mean
honestly just
a fish that's big enough to keep and
catch and cook you ever get stressed out
and keep fishing catching those tiny ass
fish and girls like i thought you said
you were good at this
no because she knows i'm really good at
it there was like professional bass
fisherman with all these like gps stuff
and
sonars around me yeah and i literally
threw out my little laura rapala
an asian baby the original gps being
asian
before that bro we go we take an asian
buddy on the fish where are they at
young sam
you're like that way i don't know if i
call him sam but yeah that was the name
young sam
young
asian people sneak that tea in there you
know oh what is it
sam and the t is silent for the most
part though yeah
that is
look man nobody knows more about getting
professional and
unprofessional psychiatric health than
yeah boy
right he is dog you gotta do it better
man with better
help you can start communicating with a
therapist in 48
hours it's not self-help it's
professional accounts and done securely
online the service available worldwide
i need it man and i need sometime i you
know i'll be in a different city or a
different state i can't get to
uh therapists that i go see in person
because of the disease right now you
can't see a therapist in person
yeah you can but listen betterhelp wants
you to start living a happier life today
and that's what they offer is the
ability
to access help over you could do
facetime call you could do it on your uh
laptop you could do a phone call you
could even do it over text
they just offer alternative ways which
are what we need now yeah man in fact so
many people have been
using better help they are recruiting
additional counselors and all right 50
states
it's popping to be a counselor right now
special offer for king distinguishers
you get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s
and if you're sitting there thinking i
need some help look get better
yeah try it betterhelp.com kats
sitting here with my boy fp
right here enjoying some
these deals they got out here you know
what makes spongebob cool
he's hairless spongebob is hairless
you guys got the same body but you all
just need to go hairless man let harry's
help you man
they got the sharpest blades ever unlike
some other razer companies they'll not
charge you more for their
product improvements yeah harry's new
sharper blades are still as low as
two dollars each a lot of companies you
call them and they're like hey i want to
get shay and they sent a dude they sent
a vietnamese dude
over there and he'll with a strong sword
and he'll you know hack at your body for
an hour now yeah looking like cat's dad
yeah those days are
over you can find harry's new sharper
blades in a big box drug and grocery
stores near you if you like to shop
online
all right you can redeem a trial off of
harry's new sharper blades by going to
harrys.com
k-a-t-s yep harry owns a german factory
that's been honing razor blades for a
hundred years man
these are finely honed blades this ain't
no freelance blade
no i mean i've seen some half-assed
blades harry's available wherever you
shop you can get harry's sharpest blades
ever big box drug in grocery stores near
you just head over to the grooming aisle
that's right or you can go to
harry's h-a-r-r-y-s dot com
slash k-a-t-s you'll get a five-blade
razor
featuring their new sharper blades a
weighted handle foaming shave gel with
aloe
and a travel cover to protect your blade
when you're on the go
just go to harrys.com cats
and redeem your trial offer today check
it out
new u.s customers can redeem a harry's
trial set at harry's dot com slash katf
there you go try it out
first time get it here's this minion
brandon what up
i got a king it or sting it for you it's
not the face mask
it's not the handlebar you already know
the king that
spring breaker you know desperate times
call for desperate measures right now
i usually get that hockey haircut that
gender neutral haircut but
all them barbers be closed so that's why
i ended up with
king or sting it what do you think and
brandon wear your helmet
we don't want you to be the next chris
benoit or aaron hernandez you're
probably one concussion away from that
so fair i don't wear a helmet or that
brain bucket
gang [ __ ] that's fair gang shivers also
no one forced you to get cornrows bro
that's a pretty extensive process to get
done
have you had cornrows cat no it's a
really it's a cat it seems like you
would have them
you'd look really you'd look sick your
sisters had them
no really no oh interesting i feel like
you have a very specific image of what
my life is
and it's not right off every time damn
whale yeah
yeah i see you're definitely cornrows a
lot of diaries
yeah diaries um they see a rap video
dowry or diary diary
cornrows is a commitment heard it hurts
too yeah i heard it hurts and if you're
in the sun you need to put sunblock like
between the little skinny areas
the younger younger wow did you wear
cornrows for your graduation
full manchu though man it's tough to
pull off yeah also girls think you're a
real creep when you got that
is that that manchu though that's that
full man chew it's
it's i thought it was foo man it is it
is i call it
full manchu yeah i like the but the full
manchu is when you also have the bottom
huh
yeah you got that baby bucket old asian
old asian guys
oh yeah asian people what are we talking
about what are we talking about yeah
tell us more chin
that's what it is is that a mustache
yeah luckily i'm one of the very few
asians that could actually grow facial
hair but it's still spread out
but this if i want to grow long it can
go forever
and why is that i don't know see that's
a flumetroo oh
damn his teeth are dope
it looks like a friend of mine that's
black magic
you have a friend that looks like that a
little bit but he's a lot younger but
he's going to look like that one
does his teeth look like that no
his name is quack quack
is he vietnamese quoc yeah vietnamese
yeah how do you know so many vietnamese
people
when i see them i say hey hey hey
and then they're friends yeah everyone
wants to be deals friends because i'm
curious we didn't have a lot of them
growing up
you know so you see him you get fired up
hey buddy
you know what y'all doing he's like who
like you know who
[Laughter]
island boy yeah you know who carl island
boy
yes they probably like that yeah they do
everybody does yeah who doesn't want to
be an island boy
i don't i bet you don't see a lot of
island boys in nashville though huh
no not really it's a little bit more
i don't i feel like i have no idea what
it's like over there yeah do you even go
there
[Laughter]
here's a sneak peek at our patreon
exclusive episode king and the sting
family reunion check it out at
patreon.com
oh there it is
dang he's in the yard what's up big z
big z first team all knows
that's my nose too bruh nose on nose
i knew that was your brother we got that
crime baby yeah what's up man
a whole lot what's happening not much
this is brendan my co-worker what's up
brother
um do it boy so that's a beach all's
white asses dude
[Laughter]
so now it's going to be questions for
zepharino and jay uh for
theo and brendan and this is where the
uh writing comes with so we can't cheat
you guys don't answer until uh theo and
brendan both say they have their
answers locked in okay do i have to draw
my wiener
only if that's the answer to the
question you just grow up man these guys
are professionals man
yeah right why they're both at home
during the middle of the day i don't
know
so far the only person whose family has
not been represented is chappelle's
we tried to reach out to your dad to get
a video but we just couldn't get one i'm
sorry
it's okay oh okay crying but don't be
sad man we got
a surprise that's what happens sometimes
chappelle we love you
we got a special in-studio guest oh yeah
the og
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and did you do it whatever you went to
prison for
legit questions well i mean
yeah that's a that's a hell of a
question
i don't know if i'm being interrogated
and here's a young fellow right here
obviously
who's uh getting some sunshine what's up
bud
hey what's up guys it's casey from los
angeles
uh wanted to talk about uh the reds game
last week with amir garrett
and uh he called himself a bad
[ __ ]
and then threw a curveball you know
uh kind of seemed like it would be
obvious that he was going to throw the
heater
so uh king it or sting it calling
yourself a bad [ __ ]
and then not throwing the heat is it an
okey doke
is it a power move or is it a [ __ ] out
let me know gang gang buzz buzz did you
strike the dude out
he did that's pretty power move you a
bad [ __ ]
let's do that nasty curve damn that's
that curve with dingy lang
whackums hell yeah you're a bad
[ __ ]
i think the reason he asked this is the
last week dave portnoy tweeted it was
kind of a [ __ ] move to
uh to not throw the heat and they
started going back and forth amir
garrett and dave portnoy
it got pretty entertaining actually amir
garrett's a badass too he's the guy i
took on the entire pirates uh
bench walker beeler told us about that
oh yeah oh yeah he fought a bunch of
pirates
oh yeah man what a g he is a bad
[ __ ]
yeah man loving war man you trying to
get the dude out
and there's only two pitches if you're a
pitcher fast one or curve one
yeah doug straight or curve yeah that's
it man
is that is that like a shitty move to
like throw a curveball yeah what is it
[ __ ] no it's baseball
oh got it i didn't know but i don't know
man part of me is like dude if you
really then you gotta
wick it past them bro you gotta feel
that that heater
you gotta throw that heater baby that
heated you gotta throw that nolan ryan
oh [ __ ] look at him come get it who else
wants some oh
[ __ ] oh damn i'm a fan damn he went damn
huh now they're getting their ass
up 11-3 but i'm a fan
damn remember when the reds had that uh
that weird
basically roseanne barr large shot yeah
marge shot died unfortunately marge is
also in big top peewee as the truck
driver
really marge oh yeah large marge you're
all gonna die
who's more shy she is the red menace
does she not look identical to large
marge from [ __ ] big top peewee
i don't think i've seen that she looks
like an older hillary clinton
yes she looks like a complete mix
between trump and hillary
yes oh yeah trump and hillary had a baby
she's a hotter hillary
yeah that's probably true hillary just
doesn't do it i've never seen
is there any pictures of her breasts or
anything like that
when her and bill were in college she
was a little bit of a baddie oh that
could be hershey went shut up but she
was a pretty baddie
college yeah they're dealing with each
other forever man
look at bill she looks chatty
yeah even the picture seems like i'm
already having a listen to stuff and he
looks stoned as
[ __ ] feel like a party you think
hell yeah hillary was his side piece dog
i don't know look at that dude i don't
know i do
that's the main the main she's gangster
man
yeah that's the old days right there
they with each other
they in fayetteville right what is it
fayetteville arkansas
beautiful town actually i thought it was
going to be not that cool when i went
there
yeah because there's a stand up also
right well there's a place uh
let me see what do they have they have
what comedy they have a looney been
somewhere in arkansas
i thought fayetteville hasn't had
there's a new club there oh they might
there's a casino not far from there that
have that have
comedy say it will how do you say it
fayetteville or fayette you could say
fayetteville good nights
oh that's in raleigh comedy zone
fayetteville oh that's
there you go yeah there's comedies on
there that's fayetteville north carolina
we're talking about art there's a couple
of fayettevilles mm-hmm so we'll say
fayetteville
some people say fayetteville
fayetteville some people say nashville
some people say nashville
we say louisville and some people say
louisville
where lewisville i haven't heard anyone
nervous
coming up there's a lewisville texas
hold on hold on shout out to lewisville
texas oh that's what i'm talking about
louisiana
taxes got a lot of homies from there do
you they all graduated
i don't know about it did they graduate
with you though oh yeah i did not
graduate
i graduated in texas i ain't from texas
good cross-examination
i just don't want to see who's this
little front line baddie
our last king in her state
is this is that what she's actually
wearing or is this a filter with a
masking glasses
i think she's actually got it on hey
brendan hey theo my name is brittany i
am a registered nurse
on a cardiac critical care unit in
richmond virginia
and i have a kingdom or sting it
we have these little iv start kits that
have some
big old needles in them so
needles king it or sting it i'm sure
brendan's okay with them with all the
tattoos but
just wanted to know gang gang buzz buzz
yeah
does it look like i'm okay with them or
not you're familiar with needles because
you should do that decade on your ass
dude i used to do test 200 with a
homosexual friend of mine
who was one of the top probably 50 or 70
gay pride fighters boxers in america
so a lot of you guys obviously haven't
lived much and we used to stop on the
side of the interstate and
probably probably shared the needle
inject them into each other's butts no
we didn't oh really you have fresh
needles
yeah it does never bother me i can get
my blood drawn tattoos
really i don't give a [ __ ] i do not like
it man if somebody gets my takes my
blood i've had my blood taken a couple
times in here
you know i have to have somebody stand
there and talk to me or hold my hand
during it you look away no homo like
just a blood draw a regular blood draw
yeah but i give a lot dawg i don't give
like oh here's a half a spoonful
giving gallons you know here's a little
cup let me give you something it's 30
milliliters i'll give [ __ ]
a pint and a half bro take some of your
cousin you know what i'm saying give him
a half a pint
you know i'll take something that you
could give the kid or something to put a
straw in it they sip out of it in the
back seat
that true blood i'm [ __ ] throwing
throwing throwing [ __ ] anybody else
scared of needles in here
no any also i don't like needles really
only tattoo needles i'm okay with
wow that's the only one i'm okay with
i'm not scared of
i don't care about any of it yeah i
donated plasma for money two times a
week for four years in college
damn damn two times is that that
gambling addiction again right
that's just being poor in college i
guess damn why don't you donate semen
like a
[ __ ] human being i i got all nervous
and they shut me down i didn't have
enough in the cup
tried it
[Laughter]
for the cup call that shallow cup and
dude
there's nothing lame right some guy's
shallow covered in the semen
even rock bottom has wiggle room you
feel me yeah god damn
damn error quote there that's tough dude
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do damn they said you know what we're
good
we're awesome so they didn't pay you uh
no
no hey how much is it to give your semen
uh how much do you get it was a lot like
it was way more than plasma like you got
60 bucks a week but for like
four hours of time giving plasma for
semen it was like a couple hundred
dollars are you gonna figure out
any other way to make money nick i had a
job
i worked full time all during college
and you needed how much money did you
need
you're making like ten dollars an hour
i'm paying rent yeah yeah regular job
really in college
not everybody is an athlete that gets
everything taken care of for them
okay some of the people in this room
didn't even finish high school because
of certain issues they had going on in
their life right
what i'm saying is nick obviously was
working at the bookstore he was
he was about to quit college to gamble
okay nick what would you do with your
money in college
uh pay rent food groceries and
try to go home once in a while what do
you think you would buy my car
suit suits
yeah i mean it was half my plasma there
was actually a guy at the plasma clinic
because they would you get a little
receipt and had a number and you go up
to an atm
and there was a guy who just sat there
and sold weed to the atm
and uh yeah that's that was that's where
your money went
that was just the extra and it was a
nice gig because you could sit there on
your laptop watch a movie do some
homework
how much how long do they take it out if
you think about a half hour an hour
four i could do it in 40 if you pump
real hard oh oh
right it would go in cycles you'd go
like 10 minutes on then 10 minutes relax
and they put saline back in then 10
minutes on
and then and then oh man it's all 60
bucks
it's all coming back to me because there
were cycles and after it would stop and
you had to get to this one line
and like on the third cycle if you were
just short you had to wait like a whole
another 25 minutes
another cycle so that last one you're
like are you doing how many times a week
two times
you could only go two times a week and
there was like there's a payment cut off
for 175 pounds
the second time of the week you got
instead of your second time you get 25
but if you're over 175 pounds you get
35. so i'd wear my winter coat and like
extra clothes because i was right on the
border of 175 pounds
wow right you're pushing the limits to
get that extra
you can't donate blood if you've got
tattoos you know that uh
like recently if you got them like
within a year you can't donate blood
oh you have to wait a while yeah i can't
donate blood because they're using
because using steroids yeah
really they have to use the intravenous
drugs ever
or intra intramuscular too i think so
yeah it must have because i told them
this
we can't take your blood i said damn all
right
yeah and i already had it out of me
[Laughter]
what'd they do with
she went to that jackoff clinic i'm not
doing that i have a buddy who got a note
in the mail the other day and said he
has like 11 children out there that's
too crazy to me so that's what they do
with the semen oh yeah give it out you
seen that vince vaughn movie
where he was like delivering kids
delivery man
well one of the crazy true story too
here's a thing you don't know that goes
on a lot of these women who are in
beauty pageants
beauty women like miss america yeah miss
america miss whatever miss
miss yeah miss haystack miss frickin
uh miss ventura miss napalm or whatever
i don't know what it's like in some
countries but
you uh they they
um those women will donate their eggs
that's how a lot of those women make
money you're wondering how a lot of
these hot girls make money and how
they're surviving
and you know like what is it like bang
energy isn't paying all these women
you know that skinny tea can't pay
everybody
totally and it can't so how they're
doing it is they're making big money
selling their eggs because then a lot of
men will just be like well i already
have every
i like what i have in my life i have you
know i like how i think i just need more
attractiveness
so then they go to those egg farmers and
they say hey let me get an egg out of
you know
miss uh south dakota you know 48 or 71
or whatever i feel like that's a hard
road some
but some of them instagram thoughts also
just selling their body
well someone were selling body yeah but
some of them are selling eggs
selling sex selling oh something sick
but some of them selling uh
eggs is much more lucrative though you
can get 30 000 for a batch of eggs if
you're smart as well
you were considered that cat uh i looked
into it for a certain amount of time in
college
i will sell it be honest now let's all
get honest here
there we go now college is what's after
i don't want to i don't want to shock
you
[Laughter]
new realms like here's a picture of me
in college dude and it's him and it is
right if he was born
[Laughter]
he's like i was eight pounds 11 ounces
ufc louisville
[Laughter]
it was hot as hell i'm like that's an
incubator
but so you looked into it so you've
heard of this this is a thing that women
think about
yeah me and a bunch of my friends were
trying to figure out how to make money
in college because we're all broke
um there was a girl who ended up selling
pictures of her feet
and then another girl said oh can we
sell our eggs the same way guys can
sell their sperm and so we tried to look
into it and what ended up happening is
like
it's weird because the process is so
invasive but you could get a lot of
money for a couple eggs
you guys decide not to do it though yeah
no
the feet picture seemed like a better
deal your
feet picks i did sell pictures of
somebody else's feet for a short amount
of time
amen and shout out jason tebow who i've
used his penis picture before
girls do that a lot with nudes too
they'll send
uh their friends nudes to a guy because
they're like oh like
i'm on my period right now i'm bloated
or something can i use your nudes and
send it to him
and we'll do that that's cool wow you
know what that's called it's called
teamwork
teamwork it makes the dream work wow it
makes something work
can you look up the uh call how much an
egg is for a woman because here's now
you want to talk about
disparity in the wage gap i'm going to
show you
right here from the beginning
whoa look at this look at the cost on
this what is it
twelve thousand dollars well we made ten
thousand
dollars you guys make sperm ten thousand
dollars
previously donated has paid twelve
thousand yeah fuse approved if you're
like a grade a donor
so it says egg donors are paid for every
donation have the potential to earn at
least 70 thousand dollars
after completing multiple egg donation
cycles
wow the first time egg donors paid 10
grand
i jack off in a cup i get 300 bucks
that's what i'm saying if you have
enough yeah if you have enough you show
up a milliliter shy dude
nothing's spilling over and you're back
at the bookstore somebody clean it up
back at the bookstore trying to dinner
paid to get a parlay to pay for rent
yeah
yeah look how vague it is dude men are
paid
anywhere from 35 to 125
show a little pride bud 35 to jack off
in a cup
and you got to hit the cup man you know
what he's saying yeah you gotta hit the
cup they should give you an extra ten
dollars for getting it in the cup
mm-hmm i had a buddy that paid four
hundred dollars to jerk himself off
wait what are you back himself he went
to sleep
he was at a whorehouse oh he did it oh
and got a hand job but they made him do
it yeah
damn your boy got hustled yeah
y'all too green behind the ears yeah she
snatched my money out of my hand
also some dude knocked on the door he
said time's up and i was like
then i had to wait for my buddy because
he was still in there and they were like
your friend's going to be a little bit
longer
and so he comes out i was like what'd
you do he goes oh i just
paid 400 dollars just to jerk myself off
and
you know i looked at her i was like what
yeah
yeah oh we did dude you could do that
what a waste of [ __ ] somebody because
i was going to college
yeah i was and it was like he was like
college yeah this was this sounds like
something in mexico i was just i was
just going to college he was like yo
let's do something
you know like it's your last night in
town it's good
so i can jack off we didn't know it was
a whorehouse it looked like a strip club
no that wasn't in louisville that was
back home in arizona
well also one thing yeah when i lived in
tucson man it was easy to get down to
mexico and get into trouble you could
buzz right down there and
jerk off over there for you know thirty
dollars they got them donkey shows in
mexico now
yes but a lot of the donkeys are uh i've
retired at some of the greats
yeah they go those long stretches
oh yeah long stretches
yeah dude how long does a donkey last oh
they got years bro
yeah pumping they got a little uh they
got this little seabiscuit junior down
there that i've seen before
junior
it sounds like it sounds like a nice
time don't it tacos
see a donkey show then when you actually
see how the sausage is made it'll break
your heart man
damn yeah man you got to go down there
and see the little seabiscuit junior
you think nick's [ __ ] giving us a sad
story about jacking off and donating
blood in college yeah
somebody's mexican women the things they
got to do just to [ __ ] sleep at night
man nick's so confused he's jacking off
at the blood
[Laughter]
you're gonna tell me he doesn't have
enough just so we can quit school
and bet on barley thank god
i should have read this guy's resume i
know that
um he's a hard worker though i'll keep
going man
the guy i'll keep going what else were
we talking about
so i can't believe that so can i so
that's a real thing that women do cat
yeah i mean if times get rough let me
know if somebody wants an egg
wow now a lot of women are freeze eggs
if they're single they're just kind of
ass if they're 37. you can't get a man
so they freeze the eggs
now if you look also nick can you go to
one of those sites where you get to pick
the woman whose egg you get
now that's where you do it's kind of
like uh is it like a menu
yeah and you could say okay what about
this one when she was miss colorado oh
that's cool 1994. let's see what she's
got
now with crispr technology too you'll be
able to pick color
their eyes height weight wow yeah
yeah yeah they're called designer babies
right
wait what so that's why when you see
these men they got this baby and look
like people are the rich are just doing
what they want to do man
mm-hmm it's crazy look how happy those
two are meanwhile the rest of us poor
people
got to keep [ __ ] each other down here
outside of the bank and hopefully
something works out
yeah hopefully hopefully every now and
then somebody breaks through the
freaking
you know into gets past the velvet rope
damn my sister got six kids
does she same baby daddy too damn
[Music]
now who are all these people these
people you can choose nick yeah to see
their pictures we gotta register
but uh uh get there you can get jamaican
danish
look at that you go full dane she's five
eight damn five eight one
seven you get that little thick baby oh
she could win a westminster right there
that's blue ribbon education trade
school
[Laughter]
oh this one's a dime five six 117
masters degree jeff i wouldn't bring it
up if you didn't keep showing us
pictures from high school
i agree man you brought the sun yourself
yes he's like here's a picture when i
graduated with him in an easter egg on a
church
and he was seven years old like
is that it nick that's it how long do we
go
it's a hour ten damn oh damn seems
longer sometimes
you got that easter outfit yeah i do
you can see chappelle and his easter
outfit uh chappelle when he ran the
class president yeah yeah
hey go go to my ig it's on my ig
this is a little easter outfit you see
you mean my little sword you need to
bring that easter outfit to
dallas tonight you me oh yeah malcolm
dallas thursday friday saturday yeah
addison improv science that's an improv
let's do it
bring this hat where am i going scroll
down scroll down
i know i got that easter there it is
right there right there
baby see you in the middle right there
look at me go
again not graduating i mean yeah he's
like here right here's one i got my
first job out of college at the bank and
you're like
kiki look at nine i'll go home and find
the high school picture
i know i have it yeah the high school
picture let me know when you find it
no i got it i got it i got it he's gonna
bring in a drawing
[Laughter]
dude i'll tell you this on my graduation
man my brother was and his friend were
supposed to come to it
and uh this is high school yeah and it
meant my brother ended up
i think for some reason he couldn't come
but his buddy his buddy came that i
barely even knew him
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh congrats was wasted bro his friend
was
wasted dude like it was like a like a
year like a soccer game
in [ __ ] uh spain this dude was
bombed eating shrimp he got nothing from
somewhere
you could tell nobody was even sitting
by him it was a packed place and it was
so nuts oh that was
oh yeah yeah that's right
boy he did it five years steve
[Laughter]
uh i think it was probably from drug
overdose but
good guy man r.i.p big johnny get up
silver
gang man brendan and theo fighter and
weight i got to go in and go hard in the
paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go i need a sponsor
i am a monster about to open up with
this at my concerts flow is contagious
browser outrageous thicker than girls
that are instagram famous damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ain't the queso and the
quesoritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude got a
pack of matches in his pockets at all
times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string